we're told to consider the complex
number z is equal to negative one plus i
times the square root of three find z to
the fourth in polar and rectangular form
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together so first let's just think about
what the
modulus of z is
we know that the modulus is going to be
equal to the square root
of the real part squared plus the square
root of 3 plus the imaginary part
squared so it is going to be
negative 1 squared
plus square root of 3
squared which is going to be equal to 1
plus 3 so principal root of 4 which is
equal to 2.
now the next interesting question is
what is the argument of z
and the reason why i'm even going
through this is once we put it into
polar form it's going to be a lot easier
to both visualize what it means to take
the various exponents of it and then we
can convert back into rectangular form
and so let us let me draw another
complex plane here
imaginary axis that is my real
axis
and if i were to plot z it would look
something like this we have negative 1
in the real direction so that might be
negative 1 there and we have square root
of 3 in
the imaginary direction square root of
3. so our point z is right over here
and we know the distance from the origin
the modulus we know that this distance
right over here is two
we know that this distance right over
here is square root of 3 and we know
that this distance right over here is 1.
and so you might immediately recognize
this as a 30-60-90 triangle because in a
30-60-90 triangle the short side is half
of the hypotenuse and the long side is
the square root of 3 times the short
side so we know that this is a 60 degree
angle we know that this is a 30 degree
angle and the reason why that helps us
it's hard to see that 30 degree the
reason why that helps us is that this is
60 degrees we know that the argument
here must be
120 degrees so the arg of z the argument
of z is 120 degrees
and so just like that we can now think
about z in polar form so let me write it
right over here we can write that z
is equal to its modulus 2
times the cosine of
120 degrees plus i times the sine
of
120 degrees and we could also visualize
z now over here
so its modulus is 2 so that's halfway to
4 and its argument is 120 degrees so it
would put us right over here this is
where
z is
now what would z
squared be
well when you multiply complex numbers
and you've represented them in polar
form we know that you would multiply the
moduli so it would then be 2 squared so
it'd be 4 right over here and then you
would add the arguments so you would
essentially rotate z by another 120
degrees because you're multiplying it by
z so it's going to be cosine
of 240 degrees plus i
sine
of 240 degrees once again 2 times 2 is
equal to 4 120 degrees plus another 120
degrees is 240 degrees and so now where
would z squared sit
well its argument is 240 degrees and its
modulus is four
so now it is twice as far from the
origin
and now let's think about what i'll do
this in a new color what z to the third
power is going to be equal to
well that's going to be z squared times
z again so we're going to multiply 2
times this modulus so that's going to be
equal to 8 times and then we're going to
rotate z squared by 120 degrees so
cosine
of
360 degrees
plus
i sine
of
360 degrees and so that's going to put
us
at 8 for our modulus and 360 degrees is
the same thing as 0 degrees so we are
right over here so this is z
to the third power and i think you know
where this is going
what is z to the fourth power going to
be let me move my screen down a little
bit so i have a little more real estate
z to the fourth well i'm just going to
take this modulus here since i'm going
to multiply z to the third times z i'm
going to multiply that modulus times 2
to get to 16
and then i'm going to add another 120
degrees
well i could write cosine of 480 degrees
or 360 degrees the same thing as 0
degrees so this i could say is 0 degrees
this is 0 degrees so if i add 120 to
that i get cosine
of 120 degrees plus i
sine of 120 degrees
so my argument is back to being at 120
degrees but now my modulus is 16 so
there's 4 8 12 16. this outer circle
right over here i am right over there
with z to the fourth so we're almost
done we've just represented z to the
fourth in polar form now we just have to
think about it in rectangular form
now lucky for us we already know what
cosine of 120 degrees is and sine of 120
degrees is
it is we can construct if we want
another 30-60-90 triangle right over
here so the hypotenuse here
has length 16
the short side is going to be half of
that so it has length 8 and then the
long side is going to be square root of
3 times the short side so it's going to
be 8 square roots of three so if we
wanted to write z to the fourth in a
rectangular form it would be the real
part is negative eight
plus i
times eight
square roots of three and we're done